met by chance together by faith
Bound by horror
it's a story line for the new season of
Asylum and hotel fear yeah we're talking
about a haunted house it's an experience
back at the Meadows Mall again as we
head towards Halloween Candace Charles
you're live there hopefully you're gonna
be okay things seem nice and peaceful
and tranquil and calm there hopefully it
stays that way yeah
I'm hoping so too John and Heather
um I've taken a deep breath I've drank
some water so I think I'm ready for it
this is the part that we were last at
actually in the Asylum
um I'm joined by The Man Behind this all
rich relax and honestly his story is
quite interesting he started doing
haunted houses like when he was 10 years
old kept going with it and now he's
created this amazing one where 20 years
in the future from the original white
right one so tell me a little bit about
the storyline as we walk through this
well we're going back through the
through the Asylum now 20 years later
there's been problems with the uh with
the different uh
patience going on in here so you're
actually going to be a uh
to find out what's wrong what's going on
in behind the scenes of the of the
Asylum and when we do something goes
wrong the doctor has been killed the
patients are loose and now you're on
your own in the Asylum okay that that
isn't really prepared for being on my
own but um I think that you know it
seems like it's not too bad any any
advice you give to people going through
these haunted houses uh go with a friend
okay that's good to remember it's always
someone to hold on to and someone to
hide behind yes that's definitely what I
was doing with the original I appreciate
that you're doing a good job thank you
so much for joining me this morning you
got to enjoy or check this out yourself
as John said maybe not enjoy but let me
check it out yourself Thursday to Sunday
at 6 30. and of course we'll have the
details about the tickets and everything
and more on our website newsdown.com if
you guys have a detox back to you guys
in the studio
I think I heard something man he said go
with a friend I'd need a bodyguard
please oh wow okay Candace thank you
very much hold on to the wall yeah
clutch onto something there my goodness
that's terrifying it's Halloween and I
totally can't wait to go thanks Candice